In Unit 4, you mentioned that you would tend to store the secret key
in a completely separate machine from the one you were developing on
and you mentioned the concept of a production machine.
Some of our students were wondering if you could go into that a bit more of that. >>Sure. Sure.
We can definitely talk about that--there's a few little edge cases, nothing major,
that we'll just talk about here on the white board and it should help you out.
How to have a distinction between production and development.
The way we've always structured stuff on my project is we'll have a file.
Usually we call it like--production.py, and depending on the framework we're using,
sometimes this kind of notion is built in--when you launch your program locally
you say something like dev_app whatever--I don't know--let's not complete it
and you can give a bunch of configuration options.
Often you can give it a configuration file as well.
This isn't always the case--sometimes what we do is in a simple case
we just have production.py and we'll have the devel.py.
These are both basically have a bunch of global variables--things like secret keys
that you're going to use for your cookies or the passwords--that sort of thing.
We'll have one that's only use in production and one that's only used in development.
And this one maybe included in our repository and this one may only exist in our servers,
or you know may exist in our repository but generally we don't like that stuff
getting shared around, especially if it's open source.
For example, Reddit's open source, so we don't include production.py publicly,
but I think we do included devel.py for you guys to use locally.
And then when we deploy code on our own machines, we just symlink
to config.py whichever one we want--so I think our apps by default, look for devel.py and--
and if it's not there, uses config.py which may symlink to like production.py.
We also have a bunch of different configuration files--if whether you're an app server or
whether you're a database or--because we have all these different machine that serve
different purposes--so I put all my stuff in one module and then we have this--
complicated symlink set up when we do deployment that basically says this app server
is doing this job, therefore it should use this file
and you can copy to place the symlink that you can do all sorts of clever stuff.
Sometimes, it's built into the framework. At Hipmunk, it's built into the framework.
We just say ff.py is the name of our main executable and I can just say--
dash dash dash dash config equals and always specify one of these files and that was great.
There's no easy correct answer or simple thing.
Store your globals and different files if you want to keep them secret and when you're deploying it
kind of figure it out how to decide which value you want to use--hope that helps.